Vor der amerikanischen Westküste geht etwas
Seltsames vor sich.
Schon seit einiger Zeit entweicht dort massenweise
Methan - und zwar aus hunderten von Quellen
auf dem Meeresgrund.
Diese Blasen entweichen genau in der Region,
die tektonisch gesehen zu den gefährdetsten
der ganzen Welt gehört.
Sind sie die Vorwarnung eines riesigen Erdbebens?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Die Gas-Ströme entweichen aus der sogenannten
Cascadia-Subduktionszone.
Diese Region ist bekannt als Hochrisikogebiet
für die vielleicht krassesten Erdbeben weltweit.
In einem Abstand von wenigen Jahrhunderten
kommen hier schwere Erdbeben mit verheerenden
Folgen vor.
Das letzte Mega-Beben fand im Januar 1700
statt - ein gigantischer Tsunami war die Folge.
Heutzutage ist die Region dicht besiedelt,
denken wir beispielsweise an den Ballungsraum
Vancouver-Seattle-Portland mit Millionen von
Einwohnern.
Ein schweres Erdbeben hätte katastrophale
Folgen, denn wirklich erdbebensicher gebaut
wurde erst ab den 80er-Jahren.
Die Erklärung für das Entstehen von Erdbeben
in dieser Region ist ganz einfach: Denn in
dieser Cascadia-Subduktionszone treffen kontinentale
und ozeanische Krustenplatten aufeinander.
Die Folge sind dann sogenannte Subduktionsbeben;
die stärksten Erdbeben überhaupt.
Auf der Richterskala erreichen solche Erschütterungen
Magnitude neun.
Oft dauert das Ganze länger als eine Minute
und die Schätzungen zufolge entspricht die
freigesetzte Energie dem Einschlag eines ein
Kilometer großen Asteroiden.
Was passiert hier genau?
Durch diese Kollision der kontinentalen und
der ozeanischen Platte wird die ozeanische
Kruste in den Erdmantel gedrängt.
Der Kontinent wird an der Subduktionszone
zusammengeschoben und die vorderste Kante
folgt der absinkenden Platte in die Tiefe.
Die Kruste dahinter wölbt sich auf und ist
gespannt wie eine Feder.
Irgendwann wird die Spannung aber zu groß
und die Kontaktfläche schnellt in die Ausgangslage
zurück.
Dabei wird dann das Wasser darüber verdrängt
- und eine gewaltige Welle entsteht, die sich
in Richtung der Küste bewegt.
Doch nicht nur diese krasse Energie ist typisch
für die Prozesse der Subduktionsbeben, sondern
eben auch, dass sie relativ regelmäßig auftreten.
Deshalb sind Forschungsteams mit Hochdruck
dabei, die Beschaffenheit des Meeresgrundes
in dieser Region besser zu verstehen.
Eine wichtige Hilfe könnten die Methan-Blasen
sein, die seit einiger Zeit vor der amerikanischen
Westküste entweichen.
Schon 2009 wurden die ersten Methan-Austritte
vor der Küste des Bundesstaates Washington
aufgespürt.
Doch was der Forscher Paul Johnsen jetzt mit
seinem Team entdeckt hat, überrascht selbst
die Fachleute: “Wenn man den Meeresgrund
von Vancouver Island bis zum Columbia River
entlang gehen würde, wäre man nie außer
Sichtweite einer Blasenwolke”.
Heißt also im Klartext: Der Kontinentalhang
vor der US-Küste ist übersät von solchen
Methan-Austritten.
Insgesamt 491 Cluster werden durch 1.778 Gasquellen
auf dem Meeresgrund rund 50 Kilometer vor
der Küste gebildet.
Das Aufspüren solcher Methan-Quellen funktioniert
übrigens nicht nur mit sehr speziellen Messverfahren,
sondern auch mit einer anderen - eher kuriosen
- Methode.
Und zwar durch die Analyse von Satellitendaten.
Das Forschungsteam weist darauf hin, dass
sich häufig eine große Anzahl an Fischerbooten
um die Austrittsstellen von Methan bilden.
Der Grund dafür ist einfach.
Fische sind dort auf der Suche nach Lebewesen,
die wiederum Mikroorganismen fressen.
Und diese wiederum bedienen sich am Methan.
Der aktuellen Analyse zufolge befinden sich
die Methanquellen in einer Tiefe von etwa
160 Metern.
Auf einem schmalen Streifen von maximal zehn
Kilometer Breite.
Und zwar genau an der Stelle, an der sich
die sogenannte ozeanische Juan-de-Fuca-Platte
unter die nordamerikanische Kontinental-Platte
schiebt.
Durch diesen Prozess werden Sedimente abgeschabt
und zwischen den Platten zusammengedrückt.
Dabei wird Methan herausgedrückt und entweicht
in Form von Blasen aus dem Meeresboden.
Eine weitere Erkenntnis: Die Methan-Blasen
treten eher im flachen Wasser auf.
Das alles lässt das US-Forschungsteam vermuten,
dass die Platten bei einem starken Erdbeben
in der Region übereinander geschoben werden
und dabei Brüche entstehen, durch die das
Methan nach und nach entweicht.
Dazu Johnsen: “Die Risse in dieser tektonischen
Grenze liefern die Pfade, durch die das Methangas
und warme Flüssigkeit aus dem Tiefen entweichen
können”.
Bei einem Beben des Meeresbodens im flachen
Wasser nahe der Küste, könnte man also einen
kleineren Tsunami erwarten als bei einem Beben,
das im tiefen Wasser stattfindet.
Sprich: Die Methanaustritte können die Vorboten
eines großen Bebens sein und betroffen davon
kann die komplette US-Westküste sein.
Das heißt nicht, dass das Erdbeben auf einmal
überall auftritt, aber das im Laufe der Jahre
die gesamte US-WestKüste betroffen sein könnte.
In Los Angeles und San Francisco wird ja schon
länger ein großes Beben befürchtet.
Mit hoher Wahrschauínlichkeit wird es im
Laufe der nächsten 20 Jahre stattfinden.
Die Methanblasen im Norden könnten der Vorbote
eine Verkettung von Erdbeben sein.
Es wird mit 10 tausenden Toten und Milliarden
Schäden gerechnet.
Und, es wird aus heiterem Himmel kommen.
Niemand kann es genau vorhersagen. da helfen
auch nicht die Methanblasen.
Mehr zum Thema: Tsunamis | Einfach Erklärt
Anklicken, anschauen und natürlich Raumzeit
- Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.